It was New York City in the 1960s, and the
city was lit up with color and life 24 hours
a day.
From the Mad Men of the Madison Avenue advertising
companies, with their crisp pressed suits,
slick haircuts, and even slicker salesmanship,
to the revolutionary art and culture of Greenwich
Village, it was the place to be.
From dusk until dawn, then all throughout
the day, the streets were positively flooded
with people on their way to work, heading
out for a night on the town, or looking to
get into some trouble.
It wasn’t likely that you would notice one
man keeping to himself, his hands in his pockets,
the brim of his hat pulled low over his forehead
and casting a shadow over his eyes.
Unless, of course, you were looking for him.
You see, this particular man had caught the
attention of a particularly unsavory group
of fellows.
The Di Mauro crime family was not the sort
of group you wanted to get on the bad side
of, especially the family’s eldest son,
Mario Di Mauro.
And unfortunately for this quiet man in the
slate gray suit, keeping his head down, he
had found himself smack dab in the middle
of Mario’s bad side.
He hadn’t done anything wrong, really.
He’d been walking by a bakery a few days
prior, when he bumped into a little old lady
by mistake.
He didn’t mean to bump her, he didn’t
mean to make her stumble, and he certainly
didn’t intend to make her drop the birthday
cake she was holding, but it all happened
just the same.
The cake box fell to the ground, the cardboard
crumpled, and suddenly there was vanilla sponge
and buttercream frosting splattered all over
the filthy city sidewalk.
The strange man helped the little old lady
back up to her feet, and apologized for the
trouble as she cried that her son’s 30th
birthday was ruined.
He watched her adjust her hat and run away,
and felt a pang of regret, but soon forgot
all about the cake, the lady, the birthday.
Mario didn’t.
His friends called him Mario “Birthday Boy”
Di Mauro for a reason.
All year he looked forward to one thing: his
favorite cake, from his favorite bakery, delivered
to him by his favorite person, his mother.
When Mrs. Di Mauro described the stranger
who had caused her to drop the cake, Mario
decided that this disrespect, to him, to his
mother, to his entire family, would not go
unpunished.
He sent out a group of his favorite lackeys,
Bobby “The Weasel” Passarella, Vernon
“Two-Knife” Galletti, and Ben “The Mammoth”
Santoni.
They tracked the man down, figured out his
usual haunts, his schedule, the streets he
walked down every day, and reported back.
Mario gave the order, it was time to make
their move.
And so, on that ordinary day as that nice,
neat, polite man walked down the street, his
cake mistake far from his mind, Mario and
the boys watched from the shadows.
Ordinarily, Mario wouldn’t involve himself
directly in this kind of nasty business.
He would send others to do his dirty work.
But this was personal, and he wanted to be
there to see the look on this disrespectful
stranger’s face as he learned his lesson.
The men trailed him all day, waiting until
it was dark, until the man was alone.
Then, and only then, they would strike.
Curiously, the man never did much of anything
other than walk around the city, avoiding
others.
If someone spoke to him, asked him for directions,
he would answer them courteously, but then
he would continue on his way.
Once, he stopped at a restaurant for a steak
and a glass of water, but he seemed to have
no job, no family, no friends, or really much
of a life at all.
Though the others were perplexed, Mario was
delighted.
There was no one to miss this man once he
was gone.
This would be even easier than he had expected.
As the streets grew darker and the night deepened,
the mobsters prepared to execute their attack.
Armed with knives, guns, piano wire, and all
their trusty usual suspects, they were poised
for the perfect moment.
And the perfect moment had arrived.
The strange man turned down an alley, and
the group followed him into the shadows.
They were just about to corner him, when the
man turned around and faced them.
“Excuse me, gentlemen,” the man spoke
in a clipped voice, refined but cold, with
an accent none of them could quite place.
“Would you care to explain why you’ve
been following me all day?
It’s becoming a bit unsettling.”
The group froze, shocked.
What kind of game was this guy playing?
“Listen here, wise guy,” Vernon said,
holding one of his signature two knives in
each hand.
“We don’t take kindly to folks with bad
manners.
We thought we’d give you a good old-fashioned
etiquette lesson.”
“Have we met?”
the strange man asked, perplexed.
“No, but we’re about to become well acquainted,”
Vernon took a step forward, the blades glinting
menacingly in the limited light.
There was nothing behind his target but a
closed off alleyway.
Nowhere to run.
“I don’t think you want to do that,”
the man held his hands up in a gesture of
peace.
“Please, it would be a terrible idea.”
Vernon laughed.
“Would ya get a load of this clown?”
Ben shrugged his massive shoulders, and cracked
his knuckles.
Bobby wound the sharp piano wire around his
fists, ready to wrap it around the stranger’s
neck.
“Enough small talk.
Gut him, Vernon,” Mario called out, stepping
forward to get a better look at his intended
victim.
“I’ve had just about enough of this.”
At his boss’s word, Vernon rushed at the
stranger, stabbing him in the stomach.
Suddenly, he cried out, one of his knives
falling to the ground with a clatter.
He grabbed at his own abdomen, stumbling back
as blood poured between his fingers.
“He cut me!”
“With what?!”
called Ben.
“I tried to warn you…” the stranger
sighed, almost sounding disappointed that
no one had listened to him.
“Forget it, I’ll handle this.”
Bobby grabbed ahold of the stranger, pulling
the piano wire tight across his throat.
No sooner had the wire tightened across the
man’s windpipe, then Bobby was on his knees
on the ground, clawing at his own throat as
he gasped for air.
A thin line of blood trickled down his neck,
there something invisible, small, and sharp
had cut into the skin.
Ben rushed to the side of his fallen brethren,
picking them up in his massive arms and pulling
them back out of the way.
“I guess if you want something done right,
you’ve gotta do it yourself,” Mario said,
pulling his favorite pistol out of his pocket
and aiming it directly between the stranger’s
eyes.
“Please, you don’t want to do this…”
the stranger begged, but Mario wouldn’t
yield.
“Oh, I very much do.
Call it a belated birthday present.”
And he pulled the trigger.
When the police arrived to investigate the
sound of gunshots, they found a bizarre sight:
Four gangsters, lying dead on the ground from
a gunshot wound, choking, stabbing, and a
heavy blow to the head.
At the center of it all, there was one man,
completely unharmed except for a hole in his
shirt and some dirt on his suit.
Unsure what else to do with the situation,
they arrested the man and brought him in for
questioning.
The murder suspect had no identification on
him, and refused to give the officers a full
name.
So, they threw him in a holding cell and designated
him a John Doe.
They questioned the man for hours, trying
to get him to explain how he had taken down
four of the city’s deadliest gangsters without
getting a scratch on him, or where he had
managed to stash his weapons before the police
got there.
Every time, he insisted: “I never touched
them.”
At this same time, the SCP Foundation was
combing their way through arrest records,
looking for any signs of the strange and unusual
passing through police custody.
They paid particular attention to John and
Jane Doe’s, looking for people with superhuman
abilities or unexplained characteristics.
The events in New York City caught their eye,
and a Foundation operative was dispatched
to retrieve the strange man from the NYPD.
They found him sitting in his cell, reading
a newspaper, refusing to answer any more questions.
When the operative noticed a large bruise
on the attending officer’s face, he stammered
“The guy wasn’t cooperating…I tried
to show him I was serious, but this happened.”
“He hit you?”
The operative asked.
The policeman simply shook his head.
“No.
I don’t know how he does it.
I hit him!”
The man was released into the custody of the
SCP Foundation, and officially designated
SCP-073.
SCP-073
is a man of Middle Eastern descent, standing
at 6’1” tall, with black hair and blue
eyes.
He appears to be in his early thirties, but
research indicates that he is much older than
that.
He looks like an average man, with a few notable
exceptions.
His arms, legs, spinal cord, and shoulder
blades have been replaced with metal of some
kind.
When asked about these metal additions, the
subject seems surprised, and insists that
he has no memory of when or why the alterations
were made.
He has a symbol carved into his forehead which
has not yet been translated, though it seems
to be Sumerian in origin.
The subject is aware of the symbol’s presence
but does not like to discuss it at all.
He becomes distressed whenever it is brought
up and refuses to explain.
SCP-073 has the needs of an ordinary human
being and requires regular consumption of
meals as well as plenty of water.
He subsists on a strictly animal-based diet
of various meats and cheeses, which are provided
for him on demand.
He refers to himself as Cain and is generally
friendly and polite to everyone he interacts
with, if a bit formal and stiff.
He is extremely helpful and has volunteered
to help out with various tasks around the
Foundation site, from cleaning and general
maintenance to assisting in research.
He prefers to provide assistance on the research
side of things, largely due to his photographic
memory, wide knowledge of world history, and
fluency in most of the world’s common spoken
languages.
When he was first brought in to Foundation
custody, he provided evidence of these skills
via a placement test in French, German, English,
Japanese, Mandarin, Italian, and a dozen other
languages, a trivia contest where he bested
the Foundation’s top historian, and a memory
exam wherein he read an entire eight-hundred-page
dictionary in a minute and a half and was
able to recite every single word without help.
In addition to his intelligence, and some
of the unusual aspects of his appearance,
the subject also possesses some impressive
and strange abilities.
Cain’s physical presence is deadly to any
life grown in soil, from fruits and vegetables
to trees, grass, and anaerobic bacteria.
Any soil that Cain sets foot on will experience
this effect, which extends to all land in
a twenty-meter radius.
Cain also has a destructive impact on plant-based
material that has undergone processing, including
paper and wood, and on produce that has been
grown hydroponically.
It is unknown why his presence has this effect,
but it influences everything from his diet
to the furniture placed in his containment
chamber.
Cain is impervious to physical harm, which
is not out of the ordinary for an anomaly
in the custody of the SCP Foundation, but
the way in which this invulnerability manifests
is particularly notable.
Any violence that is directed toward Cain
bounces off him and turns back on his attacker.
Whatever is done to him will affect the person
attempting to hurt him.
This applies whether a person means harm or
not, and whether they use a weapon or their
bare hands.
Though the harm done to Cain does not show
up as a physical injury, he does still experience
the sensation of pain, and has requested that
the Foundation refrain from any especially
painful tasks - especially since he has been
so cooperative with their research.
SCP-073’s resistance to any physical damage
has made it difficult for the Foundation to
perform any in-depth medical tests on him.
A few days after he was first brought in to
the research facility, a team of scientists
began to take various DNA samples.
At first, the process went smoothly.
They cut off a small piece of Cain’s hair,
swabbed his mouth for a saliva sample, and
scraped a few dead skin cells from the surface
of his arm.
Then, with the man’s permission, they decided
to go a bit deeper and take some blood and
tissue samples.
This is where the trouble began.
The researcher in charge of taking the blood
sample complained of a sudden sharp pain when
she pricked Cain’s arm with the needle,
occurring in the same part of her own arm.
Nevertheless, she pushed through and took
a small vial of blood.
However, when the blood was tested, it was
found to belong to a 40-year-old woman.
Somehow, instead of drawing blood from the
test subject, the needle had filled the vial
with the researcher’s own blood.
The research team tried again, with a different
doctor administering the blood test, but the
same thing happened again.
And again.
Each time, the person taking the blood sample
somehow extracted a small amount of their
own blood.
When the team attempted to take a small tissue
sample from Cain, cutting off a tiny portion
of skin with a scalpel, the same thing happened.
Cain’s skin was left completely unharmed,
and the tissue sample wound up belonging to
the doctor who took it in the first place.
Eventually, after a lot of trial and failure,
the head researcher declared that there would
be no more medical tests performed on SCP-073.
“If we keep going at this rate, we’re
going to have to organize a blood drive.”
He quipped, when pressed on the matter by
higher-ups.
Why nobody asked him to take his own blood
is, to this day, a mystery.
Because the attempts to test Cain’s blood
and other organic tissue had proven fruitless,
the research team turned their attention to
the more inorganic parts of his body.
Namely, the portions of unidentified metal
located along his limbs, shoulder blades,
and spine.
After taking a closer look at the metal, one
research assistant suggested that it might
be beryllium bronze, a metal that has appeared
under a variety of other anomalous circumstances.
SCP-073 confirmed that this metal originated
in the Middle East many many years ago, but
was unable to provide an exact date, location,
or purpose of origin.
Beryllium bronze has been identified as a
component in several SCPs so far, including
SCP-1216, SCP-1427, SCP-2481, and SCP-2711.
Further research into the unusual metal, and
its connection to many ancient civilizations,
is considered a top priority.
Currently, Cain is kept at SCP Foundation
Site-17, where he is permitted to roam freely
as long as he does not leave the facility
or come into contact with any plant-based
SCPs, or plants of any kind.
A new researcher that encountered Cain in
the Site asked him for his opinion on a bouquet
of flowers the researcher had purchased for
his wife.
Before Cain could protest, the researcher
had placed the bouquet in his hands, where
it immediately disintegrated, much to the
distress of both men.
Cain apologized profusely, and told the researcher
that he would offer to pay for a new bouquet,
but unfortunately, he did not have any money.
A memo was sent out to all Site staff later
that day to remind them of Cain’s effect
on plant-based life forms.
Due to the frequent staff turnover at SCP
Foundation sites, this reminder is issued
on a regular basis.
In addition to the reminder about plant life
exposure, Foundation staff are routinely reminded
that they must never use any violence against
SCP-073, under any circumstances.
Great emphasis is placed on the fact that
this rule is for their own safety, not for
the safety of SCP-073.
Though most of the staff know by now not to
deliberately harm SCP-073 in any way, accidents
still happen, and one careless moment could
result in unintentional self-injury.
For example, one day Dr. Byer was having lunch
in the cafeteria, walking to his seat with
his favorite dish: a steaming hot bowl of
tomato soup, with a grilled cheese sandwich
on the side.
He had specifically asked the kitchen staff
to make it as hot as possible, so that it
would still be warm when he had finished his
sandwich and several chapters of the book
he was reading on his break.
As he passed SCP-073, who was enjoying a meal
of his own, Dr. Byer tripped and spilled his
scalding hot soup all over the man’s back.
Before he could react, he fell to his knees
in pain as blisters and burns erupted across
his own back.
Cain jumped up from the table with a surprised
yell, but his skin remained unblemished.
Dr. Byer, on the other hand, had to spend
the rest of his lunch break in the medical
wing, and never got to finish that soup.
Cain is permitted to interact with other SCPs,
as long as interaction between the two is
not considered dangerous for one or more parties
involved.
He has not expressed much interest in other
SCPs, with the exception of the few that are
also permitted to roam the facility as they
please.
For example, he has engaged in some polite
small talk with SCP-507, and always gives
a friendly pat on the head to SCP-999 whenever
he bumps into it.
There is one SCP, however, that Cain has specifically
requested he never be in a room with: SCP-076,
also known as Able.
Though he has kept his personal knowledge
of SCP-076 to himself, Cain has admitted that
he knows everything about the man.
He would not elaborate further, and simply
said that it would be better for everyone
involved if the two never met.
No one knows for certain what would happen
if those two superhumans came face to face,
but, if someone as powerful as Cain is afraid
of the consequences, it certainly can’t
be good.
Now go check out “SCP 073 & 076 - Cain vs
Able” and “SCP-6008 - Noah's Ark” for
more epic anomalies!